on les appelle les ténors ses hommes
politiques déjà bien implanté à la tête
depuis des années d'un ou plusieurs
mandats le scrutin départemental
mobilisent peu et pourtant ils ont
décidé de se présenter pour le maire
d'elancourt ancien député des yvelines
il s'agit de multiplier les occasions de
récupérer des ressources pour son
territoire on est en train d'asphyxier
les communes moi je suis maire j'ai
jamais vu ça j'ai une baisse de 20 % de
mes moyens mais qui résiste à une baisse
de 20% on paye les écoles on paye les
crèches on paye les routes enfin les
vibrations pour les seniors mais c'est
ccdh a donc bien sûr que là on se dit il
faut monter il faut aller chercher des
moyens ailleurs toujours à droite la
candidature de michel laugier sur le
canton de montigny le bretonneux
témoigne d'une certaine prise de risque
maire et président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il est opposé au sortant lui aussi mère
mais socialiste à guyancourt françois de
lignières c'est vrai que c'est un combat
intéressant puisque d'un côté vous avez
un conseiller général sortant maire avec
une étiquette qui le place se ferment le
premier de tous les maires de sa famille
politique et puis son binôme qui n'est
pas du tout envie qu'ils attrapent elle
c'est la première enfin c'est la
secrétaire fédéral du parti socialiste
donc c'est sûr qu'ils sortent ils
sortent là
une équipe choc eh bien écoutez moi je
resterai toujours le même fidèle à mes
valeurs fidèle à mes principes
joséphine coleman ce berger maire ump de
plaisir ou encore philippe benassaya
maire ump de bois d'arcy font aussi
partie de ses ténors ils sont donc
nombreux à droite à avoir répondu à
l'appel de pierre bédier président
sortant du conseil général qui souhaite
l'emporter dans chacun des cantons ce
qui inquiète son opposition pierre
bédier le président du conseil général
l'ump l'ump depuis très longtemps le
conseil général des yvelines dit partout
qu'il veut faire le grand chelem donc
moi je pose et c'est pas impossible le
taux d'abstention je pose la question
aux yvelinois et je pose la question aux
yvelinois de gauche
est ce qu'il est bon pour la démocratie
locale qu'il y ait l'assemblée
départementale monocolore uniquement
représentée par des élus de droite à
gauche on notera le même engagement de
ses ténors de la responsable fédéral du
parti socialiste sandrine grand gang sur
montigny le bretonneux au maire de la
verrière alain ajaj sur trappe il m'a
semblé important de faire partie de ce
combat politique là en tant que
responsable socialiste du département
c
et je pense nécessaire qu on ait des
socialistes on est des gens de gauche au
sein de ce département on n'est pas subi
dont on sait très bien qu'on ne sera pas
majoritaires mais on tient à ce que
l'opposition existe au sein du
département dont le verdict sera rendu
comme toujours par les urnes et ce dès
le 22 mars